[Musik]
ich habe ihr leben haben das für die
show gemacht aber ich sage ich hallo
herzlich willkommen
ich möchte aber ins bild reinlaufen
nachweisen dass k s nicht glaubt dann
laufe ich hier von hallo hallo herzlich
willkommen hallo du hast du darfst nicht
verklagen da muss jetzt cool hit und
jung ja noch mal hallo herzlich
willkommen besser lief's welt was ich
dir nicht ob da noch keine gedanken wie
wir das video gemacht aber ich wollte
schon immer mal schon immer mal mit dem
backen oder kochen mit freddy ich auch
mit dir ich bin sehr froh und eine
einladung die ich bekommen habe ich hier
in einer mobilen küche
wir sind einfach kurzerhand nach berlin
gezogen ins jedoch space die küche haben
einfach mitgebracht von der messe für
mit der wg eröffnet ich wohne jetzt hier
ok jetzt zwar spaß
ich gehe wieder zurück zu lenken ich bin
ich auch unser morath aber morath habe
ich drei deswegen ja ich hab ich muss
euch sagen ich habe die letzten acht
nicht gut geschlafen denn ich hatte die
ganze zeit so kennst du das wenn du die
ganze zeit so rezepte im kopf hast und
das video in seinem geistigen auge so
vor dem vorbeizieht und es war eine
reine katastrophe etwas nämlich gesagt
es schmeckte nicht
ich habe mir nämlich vorgenommen
lieblingsspeise zu kochen das ist
ok jetzt habe ich mir gedacht okay es
gibt tausend rezepte wir machen jetzt
erstmal türkischen tee ein bisschen
abzulenken schnell
weißt du eigentlich ist ja gar nicht so
schlimm weil der murat der hat halt
absolut ich werde dich sagen keine
ansprüche aber ich habe auch gar keine
ansprüche
ja ja alles gut also ich schreibe mir
das ansonsten auch noch mal auf was du
nicht hören wird ist es schmeckt nicht
die da jetzt schon sagen es möglich
nicht nötig man nicht mehr alles damit
es nicht kommen damit klar dass mir wird
es schmecken sagt ich und du hast
wirklich sagt dann wie es schmeckt mir
schmeckt und ich probiere heute was
neues aus und zwar habe ich mir gedacht
spaghetti bolognese macht mehr oft aus
hackfleisch und ich habe den fleischwolf
mich dabei also hab ich das fleisch
einfach selber ich denke da haben wir
das früher bestimmt auch gemeint ist
klar so lieb zu mir sagen der akku ich
glaube sogar dass er italiens gemacht
wird jetzt mit ruhiger hand oder so
rannte zwischen das auch deswegen habe
ich jetzt hier schon mal fleisch geholt
drin vielleicht nicht zu mager also kein
fehler sondern eher so schmorbraten oder
nacken oder hals dann ein bisschen
sellerie eigentlich nur eine kleine
stange aber sieht besser aus wenn
märklin da liegt für zwiebeln knoblauch
eine karotte die ist von unserem garten
nicht mehr deswegen wollte schönborn ob
man deswegen sie die so ein bisschen
traurig aus weil die jetzt über nacht
hier lag aber ja waldmobil mobil ist so
ich habe schon überlegt ich habe schon
gesagt nächstes jahr würde ich gar nicht
hier im youtube space im garten hinten
hochbeete anlegen mache ich mit ja auf
jeden fall finde ich gut wie hoch wird
projekt olivenöl tomatenmark und tomaten
aus der dose das sind übrigens keine
produktplatzierung also keine bezahlte
ich hab dich selber gekauft die von
mutti sind echt die besten tomaten
die kriegt machen nur über allem aber
die von mutti ist ja gar nicht die
besten aromatischen tomaten aus der dose
weil einfach zu jeder jahreszeit
verfügbar
das probiere ich jetzt aus karamell ich
weiß nicht aber gerne etwas ähnliches
machen also nehmen wir bisschen kammer
salz pfeffer ein lorbeerblatt ich glaube
bis in kari nämlich noch mit rein und
dann wollte ich noch was weibliches
einbringen und das ist etwas luger
gleich wollte einfach etwas besonderes
machen
ok karl malz und nougat in der polonaise
ich bin groß nach jeden fall meinem
garten ok extra mit ja aber glaube dass
wir jetzt bestimmt irgendwie gut und wir
machen deinen eigenen pläne ja jetzt
machen wir hier t was für einer
das war schwach ist erhält durch das tun
ja wir schwenken jetzt n t
was hast du das thema ja ich verstehe
was das ist aber ich schwenkt das jetzt
richtig ja also darfst du hier rein
machen ja das bringt jetzt erstmal bei
jemand türke steht ja ja kaum aufreißen
jetzt auch bindet der aufreißer also ich
habe das jetzt aufgerissen ist jetzt
natürlich will das alles vernünftig
machen damit ich nicht dass er direkt
auf perfekt so okay okay so das ist
jetzt wieder drin
ich bin natürlich die kartoffel die
jetzt normalerweise sagen würde
da brauchst du keinen weil ja kummer
sind so ist einfach mit eingebaut
ok einfach da rein genau so ungefähr ich
meine gut wir sind jetzt hier einige und
der tag wird lang machen wir so macht
einfach mal reinschauen
[Applaus]
und jetzt nehmen wir erhalten von uns
motoren wasser hat und dann einfach rein
so zum schwenken also zu hause so ein
bisschen mit dem begießen sozusagen
genau so
wo da noch mehr ich hab immer du bist
jetzt mit in dieser kochwelt drin das
hat weiß nicht ob du auch diese diese
mengenangaben problematiken kennt weil
ich kann mich immer ein bisschen schwer
mit in etwa ich bin immer da ganz
genauso wie ok löffelte da mein telefon
halber teelöffel viertel teelöffel
doch diesen halben teelöffel ja wo ist
der nähe war zu erwarten aber das war
immer mein leben war wollen wir einen
teelöffel ja und immer so gestriffen
also abgestrichen so und dann ist immer
immer exakt die gleiche menge okay
halver
das finde ich jetzt schon sagen das
finde ich das ganz gut so also sind sind
die kleinen sachen so ist auch jetzt
habe ich die folgen fielen seitdem so
ein bisschen schwenken dann wird aber
praktisch sauber nein da ist sauber
haben
das hat man so alles richtig und dann
hier abgießen das ist was schmeckt so
das ist waschbecken ja wir haben noch
keinen wonach so also normalerweise
machen da sind zwar schlecht ich dachte
dass er warten jetzt auf wundern was
dann damit
und jetzt darfst du den tee aufbrühen
also dass der 1
ok ich dachte nämlich dass für die crazy
und wir stellen das irgendwie doof oder
da stellen auftragen der zsc konzentrat
und dann haben wir noch t
also ohnehin so hier das für mich schon
mehr als ich jemals gerissen hat das
reicht sagt deckel drauf und tee kann er
wieder hierhin ach so macht das jetzt
wirklich so ja da machen wir hier stufe
ist irre
nicht nur dass dieses riesige kochfeld
tausend sachen kann und es erkennt wo es
ist was wenn du das jetzt genau auf die
mitte macht von den beiden wenn es dafür
benutzte boeing sachen als zehn minuten
und was noch deutlicheres wachstum
fleisch oder gemüse machen irgendwie
gemüse glaube ich ist es den ich dann
der fleischsaft finde ich gut ja okay
dann kannst du jetzt und knoblauchzehen
magst du es ehrt knoblauch lastig oder
er ist so ja schon aber gegeben dem
anlass dass wir nie über zeit geben bei
cross videos würde ich trotzdem sagen
lasst uns doch lieber eine 10a machst du
das durch den kleinen schneiden und also
drücken oder was sie möchte es wird eine
polonaise ja aber meine wollen asse für
dich von daher alle ich wird es glaube
ich ein bisschen nur ab und zu ein
bisschen klein also kleinen süßen er
okay und ich werde jetzt einfach das
fleisch schön gemein haben das ganz okay
gut das schon bitter natürlich direkt
ein viertel von der knoblauchzehe ab ich
habe tatsächlich kein leibgericht da so
nee das ist nämlich so schwierig weil
ich für die videos meist das was ich
gerade mache zum ersten mal und dann
habe ich keine zeit mehr privat viel zu
kochen
und da ist es dann mehr so was wo
kartoffeln aus dem open schafskäse also
wirklich einfache einfach ein einfaches
handy man sich dann macht um schnell
glücklich zu hören
an der zeit lang habe ich folgen lassen
hier gegessen
ist immer unterschiedlich aber so von
damals aus der kindheit kein kein
gericht was die so im kopf geblieben ist
vorüber maßnahmen als joker jakub das
ist es doch dann der kochst du einfach
junge bürger auf mit wasser und dann
kommt joghurt rein
das schmeckt echt nicht haben kann man
schwer machen soll dabei also meine güte
also ich hab mir gedacht ich meine da es
zwischen uns sehr harmonische duin
gemerkt ja klar machen wir mal an
kirchen tausch das finde ich sehr geil
oder also ich weiß auf jeden fall dass
ich jetzt gleich schon meine assistentin
anruft und sagt euch mal bitte auch den
vier monaten konnte ich mir neben dem
emir ich liebe es also das tatsächliche
leidenschaft aufzuräumen und zu
organisieren
dessen leidenschaft ich mag das wenn
alles ordentlich ist ich meine bei mir
auch es genauso also ich schneide es
gleich hier erstmal in feine scheiben
habe gestern noch eine instagram
fragerunde auf gemacht und wir haben
wirklich unverhältnismäßig viele leute
geschrieben
ob ich denn nervös wäre ich hier im
video zu machen ich war ja du bist ja
wegen der polonaise werden
bei mir war es dann so die zuschauer
waren außer sich dem gesagt hey die
sandy dies im fernsehen und die so ein
pony bist du da wusste da aufgeregt habe
ich gesagt als ich aber gar nicht
zugesagt würde mir so hey aufgelegt com
ja aber ich bin ich bin schon ein
bisschen aufgeregt in sicht machst du
auch so zuschauer treffen und besuchst
das hat da merkst du wie du merkst du
dann wie de meist so aufgeregt sind wenn
digital kinder und jugendlichen an
sofortig stehen so und einfach nichts
spreche nicht so wie ich hier gerade als
ich getroffen habe ich auch gesagt
kaputt machen
das finde ich eigentlich ganz bewusst
wenn man unsere zuschauer auch auf ein
für uns dann gegenseitig in teams zu
kommen und wette war wir können eigene
kochshow machen wir unsere gott was
passiert mit zdf ard bezahlt haben am
wochenende das gemälde nicht und
brauchen ja nicht nur drinnen gibt es
nämlich ins studio ein kino und doch ich
habe dich noch gar nicht herum geführt
und dann kannst du da diese diese sitze
die der 40 sitze herausfahren
du kannst hier eine live sendung machen
und fragen wie eine live kochshow machen
und da könnte man wirklich teams machen
und man das rot der der kali- und der
dafür den feinschmecker macht ja also
wenn ihr lust drauf habt eine
kochsendung aber es hat die frage wird
die größeren gummis halten ich hab halt
schon eine eingeschweißte küche
community ich hab damit überlegen also
wenn ihr eine idee habt für eine
kochshow mit uns ich finde ich finde das
gut dass wir unsere zuschauer nehmen und
teams mit denen machen gegeneinander
ja aber ich weiß auch dass ich natürlich
die stark zerstört
natürlich auch das für mich wir müssen
einfach gucken was war so als themen
machen
das rät witzig bist du kompetitiv bei
sowas dann auch oder eher so wie ich bin
da mehr so dabei sein sagt
bundesjugendspiele ich habe meine gründe
leute alles gut geht mir ein wenig
genaues wird dann sache der er wir
brauchen dann auf jeden fall leute bei
uns im team die uns dann anheizen kann
jetzt kommen jetzt noch mal die
porträtierte kommt er ich bin schon
zielstrebig aber ja ich habe es mit
murat zu spielen
kennst du das morath ist so ein spieler
der der von allen gehasst wird wenn er
spielt also wenn er spielt weil perfekt
weil er weil er gewinnen muss
ja weil er immer gewinnt muss egal um
welchen preis der muss einfach gewinnen
kann nicht verlieren aber ist doch gut
wenn es jetzt kein spielt ist und man so
jemanden dem thema ja das stimmt ja aber
manchmal anstrengend ok also ich bin
voll von meinem tutorial abgekommen
ich habe mich nee ich hab mich ablenken
lassen
ich mache jetzt olivenöl war und dann
brate ich schon mal so stückweise das
fleisch schön bei hoher hitze für die
rest aromen und ich bin jetzt der der
kutscher youtube kommentar aber sally
olivenöl und hohe hitze ist es nicht so
dass verschiedene ja erklärt bitte du
musst immer raffiniertes öl nehmen
optimal anbraten und das kalt gepresstes
nicht dass mindestens 100 120 grad ist
also die grenzen habe ich glaube ich
noch so ja wenn man das erst mal auch so
nehmen oder wollen wir alles davon
verarbeiten
alles alles okay sehr gut aber ich
brauche immer in mehreren schritten an
da ich ja sonst wie die panne oder der
topwerfer einmal zu kalt und dann hier
kocht er und rät nicht mehr
das mache jetzt einfach in rostock weil
der schönheit und die hitze auch hell
und dann schön krümmel ist kross
anbraten und dann nehmen sie daraus dann
die nächste partie
das habe ich noch nicht aber ich bin
immer gleich mit zwei kilo hackfleisch
ja ganz schrecklich also hat am kochen
ich habe eine feine sache auch ganz
schlimm
erst lernen müssen und das ist mal nicht
immer auf voller hitziger
das ist schon gegen weißt du was dann in
meiner welt ist einfach wenn es wärmer
ist geht das schneller und nichts
anderes passiert da es geht einfach nur
schneller und das heißt ich habe
wirklich mein ganzes studenten leben
damit verbracht immer auf neun zu kochen
so koch auf 9 und mich dann auch oft
gewundert warum das denn dann doch so
schnell ging ja am ende des tages das
irgendwie funktioniert aber und eine
pfanne banken
wenn du sehr langsam ein jetzt nicht so
wertvolle gehört die sind auch schon in
der in der dritten generation
[Gelächter]
so sieht doch gut aus zumal kroos hat
die mit einem schlechten tag
du warst ja auch auf der youtube space
eröffnung ja immer gut
die war echt gut das erzählt ich habe zu
beginn ich habe nur gesehen hat ist ein
bühnenauftritt na ja und du konntest du
auch so einen roten knopf drücken was
hat er gemacht
ja und dann kamen ganz viel konfetti und
dann hast du den space eröffnet
ja und wir zwei wir machen hier eröffnen
grad in space soll sich das bewusst wir
schreiben gerade geschichte ja wenn wir
sind die ersten die hier videos
produzieren
das freut mich tatsächlich deswegen darf
nichts schiefgehen keine eure nein geht
ja auch nicht über meine es direkt das
erste gericht aber es war ein krasser
zeitungsartikel eröffnung des youtube
spaces berlin lahmgelegt praxis eher
fleischig oder automatisch sg 2 finde
ich bolognese soße also das gestein
geschmack treffen um das trotz an
zuweist mayonnaise ja wie wir
festgestellt haben kommen wir aus
derselben ecke ja voll schwabe
schwabe macht zwei dinge warten sagt
punkten und soße und soße ist viel soße
das heißt er fleich ich zuerst muss ich
also sehr sehr
beides würde aber so sich so nicht nur
fleisch press und tomaten
also es finden wir nicht gut also
widersprechen mir gerne wenn ich da
falsch liege aber von meiner oma mit der
guten also das ist eigentlich eine oma
lieblingsessen wir immer mit sauerbraten
los ganz klar
typisch schwäbische spätzle die du noch
selber sagte jammer nur nur leider das
rezept ein wenig verschütt gegangen über
die jahre ist aber nicht schlimm
wir arbeiten daran dass so eine familie
mission meine mutter noch immer einmal
im monat so händler und probiert da
wieder zu recreation welchem hatte aber
das ist wie gesagt
kennst du sauer linsen ja diesen auch
gut ja alles aber alles ist chemische
schwäbischen der und unterhalb punkten
das könnte sich schon ein bisschen der
wilhelms angeguckt für kapitän als wir
machen heute ja ja und den leuten sagen
ja aber was am besten schmeckt nach
einem geburtstag marmorkuchen mit schoko
überzogen am nächsten tag klein
gewürfelt in milch
da ist die connection
ich war bekommt es die bibel nur
anmerken partner ja zählt auch ein auge
zudrückt ok ja das wird viele bolognese
ok also fleisch wieder zurück jetzt ist
niebel das in diesem sommer das
schulterblatt ja ja also ich glaube das
ist auch das haben wir nicht gesehen
gerade so wie man bretter halten sollten
aber das ja nur verschuldet weil wir
beide sehr sehr groß sind ja aber
natürlich diese anhöhe hier noch ein
bisschen größer jetzt werden und unseren
195 ein handbuch das ist gerade darauf
gelegt aber wir haben ja den doppelaxel
ablagen löffel ablage okay ich glaube
wir hätten sogar noch eine zwiebel
nehmen können aber ich finde es ist ok
ganz motorrad war bisher mit an während
es an dreht ich bin dein installiert bis
nur durch gegangen mein lieblingsbild
ist dieses hier ja okay weil die pose
einfachen ja einfach da ist naja der
waren spontan ist deshalb mich so an der
hangover eben ich weiß nicht warum aber
und das hier obst hatte also ich sehe
auf jeden fall das bild noch nicht
gelegt das stört mich
dankeschön das wollte gerade mal sagen
jedes das typische instagram bild oder
ich habe meinen besten freund auf einem
hocker will mit dabei gehabt das war
dabei ein leichter ruck hier auch meist
warum mir werden manche nicht angezeigt
ich aber das wird mir angezeigt ich
kenne sehr wie die kante ist nicht jedes
land nein nein nein finde ich nicht gut
die privaten täglich zeigt jetzt noch
hierfür bestehen
und dann hast du oben das konzentrat und
das wasser nicht so
ach so ich dachte was sagst du jetzt du
musst doch nicht gleichzeitig danach
rasant
das macht ja
das erste gehört so ich mache das
konzentrat ex-bundestrainer und deswegen
glaubte erst an sagt er
es ist ja alles gut und er wird ja klar
[Applaus]
nur weil ich hier rum streichliste nicht
geklappt und jetzt was wir machen
trinken einfach regeln ohne zucker okay
gibt es nicht dann auch dass man sofort
viel zucker dabei macht das irgendwie
gibt es auch murat macht es immer aber
das ist nicht so gut für die figur so
bei mir kommen gibt's ja noch das
tomatenmark 1
ich hab also gut für ein bisschen ja ja
ich irgendwann mitnehmen müssen ja aber
das ist auch gut ich merke von mir alles
weg ja und ich hab mir gedacht ich und
du trinkst echt den ganzen tag bei uns
ist die teekanne einmal morgens voll
geil und dann bleibt die vollen man die
zum eigenen ot kamen beauftragten oder
das bewusstsein ja das internet
das hat mir deine lieblingsfarbe und
dann gibt es den tätern dann gebt steg
hatte in seiner lieblingsfarbe
ok ich kann hier nicht rausgehen und 400
sachen hingekriegt
das ist erstmal kommt zu dir vielleicht
eine vorbildfunktion für alle leute gibt
es gerade sehen weil die dich auf den
besten ansprechen werden und sagen
werden ich hab ich auch gerne im mtk
bist du nicht lieber tee kartenwerk
immer irgendwas sellerie und karotten da
bin ich jetzt gespannt
einfach so da rainha ich bin nur den
geschmack und ich als demograf mag es
nicht auf dem gemüse zu beißen deswegen
mache ich den geschmack dann nehme ich
es raus ich es die karotte und es werden
ja gut da was ich immer deswegen gemacht
haben weil meine mutter sehr ähnlichen
ansatz ist erst die karotte geschält und
angeführt wird in länge also wenn man
durch und siehe da viertel und dann halt
mit einkochen lassen 20 minuten und dann
und dann raus nehmen hatte
was hier bei uns immer gemacht den
geschmack abgibt aber mit dem mit den
sellerie geschichten das habe ich lange
nicht gesehen aber ich lieb dich nicht
du nicht magst du sagst ich habe nichts
gegen seiner die ja ich finde gerade
hier noch aufholen
es gehört ich habe nichts gegen st das
ist ja auch nicht zu viel sind ja genau
das ist nämlich immer das große problem
geht es mal wenn ich in den letzten paar
wochen immer so nur so ist ja eigentlich
steckt genau kontakt kontakt war das
immer so viel ich hatte land ihren
letzten thriller k pax das kann ja nie
ja genau genau die reaktion aber so fuhr
mit frischkäse mag ich so das ist dann
schon so low carb nach dem hit
weltwirtschaft okay ich gehe es jetzt
mal auf das war endlich zu dass du noch
deine bolo bekommst du ich hab kein
automatischer und so sich also immer 3d
schwäbisch ich möchte nach hinten
schürze funktioniert aber so gesehen
die schürze im hammer produkt wird sagen
bei dieses wahrscheinlich auch
produziert ja ich würde sagen man kann
es noch kaufen aber kann man nicht so
bisschen karama als macht das spüren
schwäbisch die dose alles ausgespielt
naja profitiert das ist eigentlich
gekleckert ab ja das stimmt
da sind sie alle gleich haben wir
natürlich hier mal kurz
ich habe schon dann machen wir hier noch
laubblätter ein noch so alles
nacheinander auch direkt also ja was
dann eine so ist jetzt nicht das man
irgendwas noch dazu oder lorbeerblätter
erst zehn minuten vor schluss habe ich
gemacht und vielleicht die sellerie
stange vorher aber ich finde es ganz gut
so dann hast du so eine polonaise
mittendrin so heile welt standen jetzt
kannst du den teelöffel nehmen diesen ja
und so ein teelöffel unten halben würde
ich sagen also eineinhalb tage frei
machen und ein halbes dutzend viertel
diesen halbe weil oft ist echt so ich
habe am anfang auch nie bei salz die
menge gesagt hier
das sei ja
gerade gut dass ich keinen zucker in den
tee wollte ich war der festen
überzeugung dass ist das nicht so
passiert so pater versteht so soll aber
viele kochanfänger die wissen nicht was
eine prise ist und du deswegen hier
hatten schon weißt du kannst ja weiß
müssen meine schlimmste debatte ist die
wir geführt haben in den küchen ein
telefon ist ein schuss
was ist denn schon in schuss und da habe
ich jetzt erfolgende theorien ich dir
gerne unterbreiten möchte er war bisher
unser profil also bei einem schuss gibt
es zwei sachen an denen man glaube ich
an dem man glaube ich so masse messen
kann
oder und das ist halt einmal das was du
hörst ja so ist das jetzt die die schuss
menge die ich reingekommen ich weiß hat
er noch ein echo
oder es ist es ist halt der die patrone
so ist es eine patronen größe inhalt und
da haben wir eine große debatte und
jetzt machen wir eigentlich die bank
naja gut also ja gemerkt ich kann das
sehr gute spieler ist das super das ist
super ja im prinzip ist es so schon mal
fertig da warte ich wollte ja noch was
besonderes
doch not macht meist zum schluss ja den
machen wir zum schluss da da habe ich
ein bisschen angst vor mir sagen ich
probiere normalerweise keine süße bei
der polonaise immer mit honig oder ja
oder schokolade ich schmeiße auch
manchmal so schokolade mit chili con
carne reine schokolade
aha ok ich muss einmal vor kosten der
frau du probierst
es kann noch ein halber teelöffel salz
ok mache ich eine private vielleicht
auch nicht vielleicht noch mal nur den
klar was eine genugtuung deswegen hier
[Gelächter]
acht perfekt ja ich glaube das passt
es ist doch gut das macht so viel spaß
wir lassen uns da gar nicht in worte
fassen wie viel das spaß mir ja nicht
gerade weil wir haben nämlich
normalerweise immer nur teelöffel bei
uns ein esslöffel und ich nenne sie
immer ganz gerne mittel dafür so viele
sagen bisher löffel dazu aber bei uns
ist immer mit allen mitteln so ein
esslöffel teelöffel irgendwas braucht
nicht eingehen mittel dafür noch zwei
spiele
ich habe meinen rosmarin vergessen wir
hängen den sich gut
jetzt lassen wir das köcheln her und
dann rudel und dann den nudeln ohne
würde ich sagen kannst du jetzt in der
zeit für mich was packen denn wir machen
auch ein bug video auf seinem kanal ok
ich bin voll dabei
lebkuchen hefegebäck suchst dir aus
da guckt da einfach auf diesen müssen
wir so ein einblendungen sagt ja einfach
dort vorbei
[Musik]
ich glaube die polonaise ist soweit
ja und jetzt nochmal den nudeln ab also
nudeln selber machen das machen wir es
heute nicht mehr weiß was ich voll
schlimm finde nudeln mit zu wenig sein
ja und er kocht ditto deswegen alle
sagen immer viel salz in die nudel aber
ich bin jude law oder nachhaltig meine
ex freundin aus meiner jugend die ich in
jedem video wirklich immer wieder abgibt
die immer öl ins wasser getan
sehen sie den sehr lieb auch im guten
auseinander gegangen aber das war
wirklich ein thema das ex freundin echt
sehen alles gut in diesen zwölf jahre
her
ich glaube niemand durchmachen so machen
wir mal ein kilo nudeln reicht das für
mich gutes ausgedrückt ist richtig ich
hatte eine butterbrezel ja also ja es
ist auch so ein regionales dinge
eigentlich ja total aber es setzt sich
langsam international durch ja hinter
durch an jedem deutschen flughafen
okay ein koch
und ich muss jetzt einfach weil ich
vorhin aber das jetzt schon gespannt
das wird mehr so weil ich es gesagt habe
muss ich jetzt komme ich mal zum stück
lukas noch rein
das hindert den geschmack ab und dann
könnt ihr hier in rosmarin einfach
entfernen
sellerie ich habe noch eine karotte ich
verrate euch wo man hier das gemüse raus
brauchst du noch eine zange oder sowas
hier perfekt du bist ja schon manchmal
habe ich meine tipps und tricks erlaubt
natürlich auch raus
der 1 ich glaube zwei okay ich hab mir
gesagt gar nicht probiert damit ich
meine so aufblühen kann ich hab dich
noch nicht probieren lassen
das hat man auch hier auf die nudeln das
sieht sehr gut aus zu sagen und ich
hoffe es reicht nicht erleben öl dran
kann als heute das sollte die top 100
meine mama hat die immer gebrochen
früheren damit zur besten job waschen
und zu essen für die kinder war es
einfacher ich habe das immer ich mache
das auch das ist gerade das packen wir
machten fast so rein gefächert
ich drücke die immer ich mach direkt
rein und drückt die dann immer langsam
runter und das dann so rum aber das ist
auch jeder mache es anders so wie einst
peter ludolf schon sagt wir machen kann
weiß machen so ist es okay dann warten
wir jetzt hier acht minuten
da geht es dann gibt es essen mit
parmesan ja
ich habe übrigens beim wetter genommen
damit finde ich besser als spaghetti
weil die so flach sind und dann mehr
soße aufnehmen kann wie machst du das
jetzt wenn du es abgelassen hat öl
butter wir uns zur bergung keine
angemacht da scheiden sich die geister
ich ganz lange mit mit öl gemacht
wenn jetzt mal umgestiegen auch so ein
bisschen butter und möchte auch nicht
weil es hat irgendwas geil ist also ein
bisschen butter drin ist weil das war
ein guter ein geschmacksträger ist
schmeckt dann wird gleich anders ja
genau also es ist auf jeden fall sehr
heftig
also macht es auch immer mit beton ein
bisserl am schmelzen mann und ich
normalerweise auch aber wer nicht sofort
so drauf machen natürlich auch gut ja ja
gespannt jetzt gemacht habe ach so ja
stimmt ich brauche auch noch einmal wie
man jetzt nicht mehr so viel sport will
ihr wisst ja also so aber ich wollte
erst mal dass du isst ich es
normalerweise nicht vor der kamera so
ach so es geht immer so weiter und so
auf malerei deswegen dann sehen sie noch
nie zu machen für uns ist es deswegen so
um alle rannten und ja okay ich bin
ehrlich muss vielleicht ein bisschen
aufgeregt ich bin nur aufgeregt wegen
diesem nubert bin ich auch ganz ehrlich
ja aber so ein kleines stück rain das ja
das ist schon
ich glaube ich bin eigentlich
rechtshänder kann man das make-up wurden
diese sogar ding ich weiß nicht ob ich
das beunruhigt über habe ich richtig
geil finde ich glaube zweiteres die lage
gut so
ich habe mal kurz ein großer schöpfkelle
aber ich hab dir schon gelegt
vorbereitet ich bin halt gespannt darauf
ob das fleisch ist auch schön zart ist
ja hoffentlich ne habe schon wieder
komplett es werde nicht viel aber ja wir
stehen hier seit fünfeinhalb stunden und
für so eine bowle aber es muss ja schon
sagen kommentar ich mag es eigentlich
chili bisschen ja aber heute würde ich
darauf wird sich ja mal verlieren können
so dass sie doch fantastisch aus wow ich
kann hier auch die effekte ein
ja ich wenn ich das sage ich schon mal
eine coole effekte ohne dass ich sagen
könnte man ihren folgen
weshalb
wow ok ok deine leibspeise ich habe sich
für dich mit liebe zubereitet werden sie
gemeinsam zubereitet und ich hoffe es
schmeckt dir ich bin ich bin aufgeregt
ist ja also wir geht schon ein bisschen
die pumpe
nächstes mal machen wir das mit seinem
herzen messgerät damit wir ihn ja okay
natürlich erstmal der klang ist wichtig
natürlich sei die optik ist ruhig so wie
du jetzt fühlt sich wie zuhause
ja klar das ist genauso würde ich da ist
und stehen vor allem das ist einfach nur
meine daily world aus es ist auch ein
bisschen zu viel
die vorstellungen sind gerade
fünfeinhalb kameras auf eingerichtet
ich habe verlangt die behörde
kate salz fehlt was schmeckt richtig
lecker schmeckt mega intensiv mega
tomatis das fleisch ist super lecker
maxity nugg.ad note überhaupt nicht und
ich glaube ich bin ein bisschen froh
drum
vielleicht ist dass der kunde
wahrscheinlich den geschmack so es kann
sein dass der euro noch dazu kommt also
es ist sehr krass aromatisch
aber wieso löcher also wirklich
übertrieben lecker sagt man meint meinte
es ernst ich war das komplette
also ich bin wirklich der wenigstens
tisch und ironisch zum menschen nein
nein ich meine das wirklich vollkommen
ernst ist wirklich sehr sehr lecker
auch wenn die kamera aus ist das rad
stand wirklich unfassbar lecker ach das
frage ich freue mich richtig über
mittagessen betragen
mir fehlt ein mir fällt ein stein vom
herzen und was jetzt mit dir du musst
das doch auch erst auch mathematik ja
ich würde sagen er zu einem messer und
gabel
also ich bin zufrieden wo ich sagen ich
hab ich geschlafen gerufen aber er lacht
ich weiß nicht ob ich dann als
hauptkamera man jetzt setzen würden wenn
wir aufhören würden erst kleine lang so
ok ich frage das also ich koche echt
nicht mehr mit chili weil ich zu viel
rein und sagen und wenn man sagt ja das
ist hier hin und nicht aber du bist du
dann aufgeht so dieses channel partner
eigentlich frische trauner frische schon
da hinten
ich weiß nicht ob steak oder ob man es
ersten darf ob ich erste gleich aber
dann schon ihr gerne gerne scharf es
wirklich mal wie stehst du dazu rahmen
sind eigentlich das getrennt haben
asiatisches essen irgendwie brauche ich
mag asiatisches essen
ok verstanden hast du gerade den löffel
schön angerichtet und ich es hier die
ganze zeit habe ich alles gut ich konnte
mir klar wir können das schmeckt das gar
nicht gelogen jetzt nicht gerade nein
ich finde wirklich sehr sehr krass
lockern
er weiß was ich meine ist halt wiebel
aromatisch comics automatisch aber auf
der anderen seite mathematisch berechnen
mission erfüllt alles richtig gemacht
alles mehr als richtig gemacht ja sehr
schön sehr inspirierend auch wieder mal
indonesien schritt weitergebracht
mindestlohn schließlich doch das gefällt
mir mit dem klein gehackten fleisch
dieser bisschen so so stück ich dann
muss man beißen aber ich gut ich bin ja
ich bin jetzt echt erleichtert
es tut mir so ein bisschen leute dass
diese im schlaf geraubt haben
er ist nicht schlimm concealer kurz
denkt anders als ihr die polonaise nach
machen wollt dann schaut auf celtics -
blog.de verein oder in der app könnt ihr
euch direkt alles auf die einkaufsliste
nämlich setzen
du warst ein sehr sehr guter fleischwolf
1 sec oder koch begleiter und ich bin
jetzt schon gespannt darauf wie dein
kuchen aus dem backofen kommt richtig
ich glaube dass wir nämlich noch mal
richtig lecker das video findet ihr
nämlich bald strom direkt auf seinem
kanal
da freuten fall schön und wenn er möchte
dass wir gerne öfter zusammen schuldig
wie vor ziemlich treten
egal ob das thema aktiv mitgestalten
hier an genau dieser stelle gerade
erledigt
gleich kommen die brüder dann schreibt
einfach in die kommentare
und ich bin also ich würde mich freuen
wenn ich dich besuchen darf und während
kirchen tausch machen ditto ich bin da
auch in jedem fall zu 100 prozent dabei
ja kann ich nur gewinnen
nach dem was ich hier heute erlebt habe
ja ich bin nachhaltig fasziniert hat das
freut mich
dank ist ja die jugend auf ja danke dass
du es extra aus köln angereist für heute
und reist heute wieder ab ich finde das
mega so wie du bist auch nur das licht
ja wegen dir danke das teilnetz das
essen mit
ich glaube schon oder die unter allen
großen teil nicht new gar nicht sichtbar
als kameramann zu sein
[Musik]